Maga is indeed melting down today the
day of Donald Trump's second arrest and
indictment this one federally in Miami
Florida by the time you listen to
Today's show it may have already
happened and we will of course have full
live coverage today as well as of
Trump's Bedminster speech at 8 15 PM
Eastern tonight hope you'll join me for
that and then we will debrief tomorrow
but let's take a quick tour through
magaland here is a former Trump
propaganda Steve Bannon who recently
attacked me and called me brother Dave
Pacman this guy is not my brother he is
now turning on William Barr William Barr
Trump's former Attorney General of
course saying if half of the indictment
is true Trump is toast we looked at that
clip yesterday and here is Steve Bannon
he's using profanity guys so that's how
you know he means business and Bill Barr
you can sit up there and say it's a
great case we're going to shove this up
your ass okay we're gonna shove it up
your ass you're you're you are freaking
guilty of treason big old you're guilty
of treason and raised guilty of treason
there is no evidence whatsoever that
William Barr has committed treason there
is no evidence whatsoever that FBI
director chosen by Trump Christopher Ray
has committed treason and I will remind
you one of the big selling points that
Trump listed about himself was that he
would hire the best people always the
best people and he hired two Traders he
hired William Barr a Trader and
Christopher Ray a Trader it doesn't say
very much about Trump's ability to
select employees which was one of the
big selling points we go now from Steve
Bannon to Kerry Lake Carrie lake is also
using an extreme filter filter on her
camera she is talking about how the NRA
comments she made how there are NRA
members who will stand between I guess
the justice department and Trump it's
not a threat she says it's not a threat
sure sounds like a threat to me take a
listen if they think they're going to
hurt lay a finger on our president
president Trump they're going to have to
come through me and I made a mistake I
said 75 million others just like me I
think it's more like 300 million others
just like me and people in this country
who support president there aren't even
300 million adults in the United States
what is she talking about President
Trump who know what's up who know that
that botched election was an attempt to
prevent him from getting in office and
cleaning up the corruption in our
country and I said I said as an aside
and most of us are NRA members that is
not a threat that is a public service
announcement it certainly sounds like a
threat and if you want to see exactly
what it leads to
freedomnews.tv interviewed Pat a trump
supporter who said January 6th is going
to look like a playground compared to I
guess what he's willing to do in Miami
later today
this is serious folks listen to this a
lot of my family blood spilled for this
country I'm not gonna let it go to waste
I'm not I refuse I did 19 years here as
a federal agent in Dade County
um
I'm just not going to let this country
go to waste and right now it's going to
waste well if he gets indoctrinated
January 6 is going to look like a
playground I assume he means indicted
I assume when Pat says indoctrinated he
means indicted
it's going to look like a playground
from the inside voices that I hear from
all the militias and everything else
it's going to be a playground but if
they want to fight bring it I mean I've
been in I watch Kamala Harris in Orlando
I watched antifa throw bottles
spit on my child
throw stuff at us they told us to
refrain ourselves really what okay but
it is what it is you know this country's
so left right now but we got to bring it
back to the right we got to get right on
the right path we got to bring
everything back if we don't we're going
to crumble
gonna be a third world nation when the
I'm telling you guys when the world sees
this this will lead to our viewers from
Germany and from the UK and from France
and from Finland and from Sweden I'm
going to get emails saying David what is
wrong with the country what is happening
there we have to stand up for that flag
we have to stand up for our beliefs
we got to put God back in this country
if we forget about him he's going to
forget about us and right now we're
forgetting him and we're forgetting
Israel we forget both of those
let's read your Bible
read your Bible because there's a lot of
boys like me that are ready right all we
need is an order we're ready
we'll leave everything they need an
order and they are ready here's one more
person they're talking to I guess
okay no they're not okay that's the end
of the interview let's hope for no
violence today that is my hope the last
thing we need on top of any of this is
to Cloud
what should be
a political
justice department actions
and court cases with the violence of
these unhinged people that's my hope
that we do not see violence today when
you're using websites and apps your
device sends out data about you into the
open who you are where you go things you
like that data then gets sold around for
advertising purposes which is why every
time I connect to the internet I use a
VPN to hide my IP address and our
sponsor private internet access is the
most trustworthy VPN on the market it's
the only VPN that has proven multiple
times in court they don't log your
activity private internet access
protects you from the prying eyes of
hackers your internet service provider
tech companies private internet access
is also super fast for streaming and for
downloads you can watch your favorite
streaming platforms as if you're in
another country like the UK to access
cool new content and with just one
account you can protect unlimited
devices all at the same time this is
really a game changer private internet
access is giving my audience 83 percent
off that's 203 a month plus four months
free go to Pia vpn.com Pacman the link
is down below